grab your chainsaws and tight-fitting
leather something that says
leather daddy oh is there such a thing
because we have the scariest thing to
come out of texas since ted cruz
netflix's texas chainsaw massacre is a
sequel of sorts we'll get into that of
the 1974 horror classic of the same name
and in this video i will be referencing
the original so if you haven't seen it
yet what are you doing it's been 48
years it's been 84 years we start on a
dvd remember those yes i'm old it's
playing a documentary about the event
that transpired in the original
colloquially known as the texas chainsaw
massacre it uses these same shots from
the 1974 film and as we'll find out from
the gas station attendant leatherface
has never been seen since i guess we'll
pretend all those sequels didn't happen
there was one survivor however sally
hardesty who became a texas ranger and
devoted her life to tracking down the
killer of her friends we'll meet sally
later on but the actress who plays her
isn't the original marilyn burns the
actress who played her sadly passed away
in 2014. it's kind of ironic that the
film starts in a gas station seeing as
much of the original takes place in one
but this place has capitalized on the
leatherface phenomena offering all sorts
of merchandise including chainsaw wine
openers one which will later be used to
stab leatherface himself we also get to
meet our new cast of characters who have
somehow bought an entire ghost town in
the middle of nowhere this is never
really explained other than dante here
seems to be some sort of well-to-do chef
who was able to get a loan from the bank
they also have a bunch of investors
coming who seem to be all college age
students they plan on auctioning off
various buildings and creating their own
utopia it's implied that part of this
utopian vision stems from our main
character lila's trauma she experienced
as a victim of a school shooting buying
this town is a way to get away from the
modern world which they see as dangerous
this is a chance for people to start
fresh somewhere without the violence and
the madness we briefly see lila check
her instagram feed where she supports
various social justice issues this one
says stop racism a nod to black lives
matter and this one's about gun control
you'll notice the hashtag stonebrook
strong the high school where the
shooting happened its name is very
similar to stoneman douglas high school
which saw one of the most recent and
tragic school shootings in u.s history
it's ironic then that guns were the
thing that almost killed her in the
school shooting yet will be the thing
that saves her in the end so i wasn't
quite sure what the filmmakers were
trying to say here further confusion is
added when lila tells her sister melody
that she doesn't want to move here
because she'll miss her friends one i
thought they died in a school shooting
and two does she really want to go back
to the high school where she saw all her
friends massacred anyways that's besides
the point i will say the foreshadowing
dialogue in the first hour is chef's
kiss yes but we have a vision for this
place all it needs is young blood wish i
now know i would come
i'd put my face on she literally gets
her face ripped off this is the harlow
orphanage a place that's implied
leatherface grew up this photo here was
taken in 1975 two years after the events
of the original film it's heavily
implied that virginia here is
leatherface's mother both her and one of
the officers refers to him as her boy
although this might be a name used to
describe all the boys at the orphanage
leatherface being her last one who never
found a home if it is indeed her
biological child she has never seen in
the original film but if it's one she
brought into her orphanage it would
suggest leatherface found adoption from
his crazy uncle and brother after the
events in 1973.
bonus points if you caught this image of
leatherface in the corner of the room
before he puts on his mask a few seconds
later he's disappeared virginia has been
running this orphanage for 50 years and
was supposed to be evicted but claims
she owns the deed to this home when
she's told she has to leave it amps her
blood pressure and she has a heart
attack prompting leatherface to join her
and the police to the hospital i enjoyed
this shot as the van leaves lila and
melody frame through meshed fence as if
our characters have just entered their
own metaphorical jail as she dies
virginia tells leatherface
let's talk to me
stay out of my room it seems as though
this woman has been simultaneously
hiding and protecting leatherface from
others she's the reason he hasn't killed
since the events of the original film
likely why it's been so hard for sally
to find him she even hid his chainsaw
within her walls why she didn't just get
rid of it who knows but when virginia
dies all bets are off it throws
leatherface into a rage that sees him
completely massacre the sheriff deputies
and this girl who added absolutely
nothing to the story i did like however
how the van crashed into a sunflower
field a call back to the original the
death of virginia gives something to
leatherface he didn't have much of in
the original motive he heads back to
town to exact revenge on these social
justice warriors not before cutting off
the face of his mother and using it as a
mask silence
of the land he even creates a grotesque
monument to virginia just like he and
his brother did to corpses in the
original his relationship with virginia
was something truly twisted as we'll
later see him hug one of her dresses and
put on her makeup something we saw done
to his mask in the original as well
meanwhile lila finds chekhov's gun i
mean richter's gun lying in plain sight
because when you have a huge gun like
this you just casually leave it out well
i guess it is texas at first she's kind
of curious about it even though she just
went through a horrific school shooting
she even implies that she's not special
because she survived her friends who are
dead are my friends were the special
ones which is totally strange because 10
minutes earlier she says seven hours by
car i guess i can say goodbye to my
friends forever you mean your dead
friends another fun easter egg is the
sound the barbecue makes when it's open
it's the same camera flash sound heard
in the beginning of the original film
now richter pissed that dante and his
crew can't provide a deed to virginia's
home proving they own the place grabs
the bus keys essentially trapping
everyone there this is great news if
you're a psychopathic killer at the same
time sally gets a call from the gas
station attendant who heard a call over
the radio about a guy wearing someone's
face as a mask she knows this could be
the man she's hunted for 50 years it's
ironic since it was a gas station guy
who kidnapped sally in the original and
now one is helping her track leatherface
sally still has a polaroid photo of her
and her friends from that fateful trip
decades ago but i'm not sure how this
photo even exists only one polaroid was
taken of them by the hitchhiker that we
know of and he ended up burning it so
not quite sure how she has this mel and
dante break into virginia's home which
they think they legally own to find that
virginia still has the deed to the house
this realization shocks melody who now
believes herself partly responsible for
virginia's death at the same time dante
gets a butcher's knife to the face
becoming leatherface's first victim in
town with melody hiding as leatherface
acquires his iconic chainsaw richter
comes to save the day but as you can
imagine this goes as well as my first
date after two years in a pandemic okay
thankfully he leaves the keys for mel
who's hiding under the bed she'll try to
escape but is knocked into the
floorboard by a flying hammer
hammer lila ends up saving mel and the
two make it back to the bus with its
keys and no one is like hey are you guys
okay you smell like actual sewage
seriously a pipe of crap falls on one of
the girls but leatherface has other
plans sawing the bus and crashing the
party try anything you cancel bro this
was honestly the most fun of the whole
movie as almost everyone is completely
massacred i even love the comments of
the people watching on live stream where
is this i want to go i've been to more
intense haunted houses before as
everyone is in the process of being
sawed to death lila has flashbacks of
the school shooting this is something
she'll have throughout the film but i do
wish the film went further and showed us
how that shooting negatively affects her
life so she'll have something to
overcome throughout the movie like if i
were to write her character i'd have a
flashback where she had a moment where
she could have stopped the shooter but
didn't because she was too scared then
she feels guilty for the lives of her
friends she could have saved she'll then
have to overcome this guilt and have a
chance at redemption by mustering the
courage to stand up to leatherface that
to me is far more compelling than what
we got i love how mel and lila
completely lock their friends out of the
bathroom who are dying outside and they
escape through the bathroom sun roof
it's here they're united with sally
who's totally gonna kick leatherface's
ass right
right
well that didn't last long one of the
things i found interesting here is when
sally confronts leatherface the person
she has thought about every day for
almost 50 years he doesn't even
recognize her the disrespect before she
dies she'll give mel and lila the keys
to her truck and just like my first
driving lesson with dad they completely
crashed the car this ends up with mel
getting a rod impaled through her leg
making lila the only one to take on
leatherface by herself sally's still
alive somehow surviving a chainsaw
through the stomach and being tossed
like a ragdoll but she'll succumb to her
injuries leaving lila to pick up the
shotgun and hunt leatherface in an old
abandoned movie theater where of course
one of my favorite films is playing
werewolves of the alambo too lila
battles leatherface and when it looks
like all is lost melody appears with his
chainsaw to save the day she somehow
disimpaled herself un impaled i don't
know so the two end up defeating
leatherface together and venturing back
home to austin texas proving that
utopias are frivolous fantasies that
will get crushed by a man wearing a
woman's face as a mask and when all
looks hunky-dory and they're gonna get
out alive leatherface smashes into the
car ripping melody out and cutting her
head off faster than you can say king
henry viii it's a pretty cool shot
because the car is on autopilot so it
just kind of slowly drives away as lila
watches in horror at our decapitated
sister there's even a fun nod to the
original as leatherface does his weird
leather dance but if you're a masochist
like myself you'll have stayed through
the credits and seen this short
post-credit sequence there's nothing
quite revelatory here other than the
fact it shows leatherface is still alive
and working his way back home this is
the same home from the original movie
you can tell by the windmill to the left
and the two chimney stacks so who knows
if leatherface has any family still back
there and what chapter of horror awaits
us next that's it for texas chainsaw
massacre i want to hear what you thought
about this sequel in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt until next
time remember try anything you cancel
bro